[Musique]
on
e
j'aime pas forcément
khalid anayat téléphone se plaît à l'eau
ça vas y toi
bats la maison
non non je suis tout seul jusqu'à forme
de nage
moi non
qu'est ce que je fais je m'entraîne à
faire remplir
bien joué contre moi écoute c simple si
tu reste plus longtemps que moi dans
l'eau je te payer un sandwich si c'est
moi qui reste plus longtemps il ya pas
de sandwich à rien merci pourquoi parce
que toi comme s'agit de lui il faut
rester trois heures sous l'eau
[Musique]
papa week end
aujourd'hui
on alla sacrément bonne j'ai bien envie
de l'aller chez
moi elle a l'air vraiment tout mouillé
qu'est ce qui vous arrive
[Musique]